ready when you are holy cow we have a
very famous experiment which has been
done for a long time in Nottingham
firing a candle out of a musket that is
156 years old and we've always looked at
it as a demonstration in the lecture but
now with a high-speed camera we can
watch how the gun operates in slow
motion and as before it's quite a
revelation we noticed things which we've
never seen before
I've got our friends in the glass
playing department to make a sort of
demonstration piece represents the
barrel and the nipple or with cushion
cap goes and it was loaded
the way that I loaded it powder in and
this stage we would put the wood in my
finger represents the hammer of the gun
which is blocking up the touch hole
that's rammed home and then we would put
the bullet and in this case with our
candle and then to hold the bullet in
another wood and that would be the way
it would be in the in its proper use
this bullet of course would be a
spherical LED ball normally at this
point we would put on the percussion cap
so remove the hammer put the cushion cap
on alright the hammer of the weapon
comes down strikes that
which sets off the high explosive in the
bottom of their sets fire to the
Gunpowder in the touch hole or the
nipple and then burns down to the main
charge here when that starts to go off
you get a rapid reaction and a lot of
heat and he's got to go somewhere and of
course it forces the bullet out there
and at the same time gives us a nice
firework effect not visible normally but
coming out of the touch hole which I
think we can pick up on Lydia shot on a
camera the gun has a hammer which you
have to pull back before you confer it
and it's got a very strong spring I can
hardly pull it back at all and the thing
that was really surprising for me
was that when the gun fired the hammer
went down and the force of the explosion
pushed it right back again something
that I need both hands to do so when you
watch it in the slow motion it looks
almost like a ball bouncing but I've
tried to pull that thing back and it's
pretty hard the other thing that is
interesting is that you can see that
when the hammer hits the actual
explosion takes place in three stages
first of all you have the detonator cap
which goes up very quickly then the
powder in the nipple catches fire and
produces clouds of smoke and then the
main charge in the barrel goes off and a
large streak of flame shoots out
backwards
the other end of the lecture hall is the
project tile from the gun hitting the
target and for our lecture
demonstrations we obviously are not
firing a bullet it could ricochet and
cause all sorts of problems so we use a
candle and what is amazing about this
experiment is they even a candle the
sort of wax candle that you burn
Christmas even the small piece of that
candle can go through multiple layers of
wood usually when we do the experiment
they're clouds of smoke and we don't
really look at the target till
everything is cleared away with a
high-speed camera we can actually watch
the candle arrive now because the candle
is not bullet shaped but is rather a
cylinder and also because the barrel is
smooth each time you fire it it comes
out of different ways so sometimes it
goes straight sometimes it falls around
in the air so each time it hits the
target is different and sometimes it
even hits sideways but the real surprise
for me was that some of the boarding the
cotton wool which is so light actually
made it across the lecture theatre a
distance of probably 10 or 15 meters and
hit the target because I don't know if
you've ever tried to throw a piece of
cotton wool but it you can't throw it at
all it so light holy cow
[Music]
I collect these from years gone by and
you can see this one here some welding
did get there and it's stuck on with wax
this one the candle broke up one piece
stopped here and the other piece made
really quite a large hole in fact there
may be more than one piece and one of
the times when we fired the musket and
film the target with the high-speed
camera the candle did fragment and you
can see the different bits arriving at
slightly different times because they're
traveling at different speeds because
they have different air resistance and
this one here made a pretty clean hole
and but you can see this is hard wood
this is not thin pieces and it's punched
holes without any difficulty at all so
if you think if that's what a candle can
do imagine what a lead bullet could have
done so you heard the professor mention
there that he likes to keep the targets
as mementos but not this time this time
I've managed to sneak them away here's
the first one with a single shot pretty
close to the target wasn't he and here's
the one where the candle broke into
pieces mice to bits of wax and wadding
all attached to it now if you'd fancy
having one of them I'm going to pop them
on eBay and you can have a beard and
maybe you can have it as a bit of
periodic videos memorabilia so thanks to
Jim for helping me sneak them out and
also uh he signed them and dated them
and by the way if you enjoy the musket
and some of the other explosive stuff
you see on periodic videos the
university actually runs a public
lecture called thunder and lightning
that they do in Nottingham all the time
sometimes it tours around so if you ever
have the opportunity and you see the
thunder and lightning lecture advertised
definitely worth checking out